okay i'm ready
what are we doing this week an old black
and white movie is this hitchcock or
something
oh reefer madness nice my hair's pretty
funny
hold on let me grab my chips
all right hit it you're ready for a
bunch of
one sec get ready for a movie that's
supposed to scare young people off pot
by lying about how bad it is for 90
minutes straight
and they still can't help from showing
you how it's cheap taking stupid pieces
from kids
grows easily it grows wild in almost
every state in the union
and will basically get you laid on the
spot man i wish they were true in real
life
way to make pot look even better movie
return to the 30s
when every kid in high school looked
like they were in their 30s
and even potheads wore a full suit and
tie as you're introduced to eddie
well hello gwen it's all right ralph
oh hello kenny teddy teddy
yeah there's no way i'm keeping all
these mayo ass names straight what's the
main dork's name again
bill bill okay bill that'll work
follow along with bill a loser who's
hopeless with girls and bullied by
children
mom make them cut it out who develops a
condition where he can't stop laughing
until he finally snaps and shoots
somebody
so it's like the exact same plot as
joker
experience a film that was scandalous
for its time because a girl rolls down
her stockings or whatever
but is mostly just boring really really
boring
as you sit through the most depressing
opening crawl since ryza skywalker
sit through marathon pta meetings and
sit through
a slow courtroom drama that would make
any teenager want to jump out a window
actually you know what can we just bail
on this one early whole film's a huge
bummer half of it is just boring and the
other half is just freaks playing piano
laughing at each other
in the 30s this was basically wob enough
okay
kill my buzz can we watch something else
that's what i'm talking about now where
did i leave benedict cumberbong
oh there you are
okay much better spark a j
pour yourself a white russian and relax
for the most chilled out la detective
story since the long goodbye
or cutter's way you know nine moves was
pretty great oh then there's devil in a
blue dress
and you've seen inherent vice right i
guess faded la detective noir is like a
whole genre huh
wait what movie was i talking about
again come on man
right the big lebowski
best film ever you
know this movie even if you've never
seen this movie you know it
yeah well you know that's just like uh
your opinion man you even know the tv
edit
see what happens when you find a
stranger in the alps it's like pop
culture hurt immunity
the film's crossed over into the shared
cosmic unconsciousness
boy i'm flying oh get a hold of yourself
happy boys guys
but for real this film is such a cult
hit their entire fan conventions
this poster was on half the dorm rooms
in america and there's a lebowski
challenge where you drink a white
russian every time the hero does
which i do not recommend because i mean
wow
that's a lot of dairy right along with
the dude
he's less of a character than a way of
life jeff bridges cruises his way
through a plot that needs a flow chart
to follow
until you and he both stopped trying to
put the clues together and just enjoy
the ride
this is a very complicated case mod you
know a lot of ends a lot of outs a lot
of what have you
in a comedy that you don't really get
until you've seen it like three or four
times
it doesn't have jokes per se but just
weird characters repeating themselves
into the humor cracks your brain open
sometimes there's a man sometimes
there's a man where's the money lebowski
where's the money lebowski see what
happens lebowski you see what happens
stay out of malibu lebowski stay out of
malibu
dead feet strong men also cry
strong run also her life is enormous
her life is in your hands dude they're
gonna kill that poor woman
they're gonna kill that poor woman he's
a good man
i'm thorough please see him jeffrey he's
and thorough they did not receive the
money you nitwit they did not receive
the money he believes in nothing he
believes in nothing
is this your homework larry is this your
homework
you see what happens larry you see what
happens larry
rowing my bag but the dude doesn't roll
alone
hit the lanes with walter who was
extremely loud and wrong before the
internet made it fashionable
if he's not ranting about the war in
vietnam he's finding ways to make
everyone else's life harder
especially donnie's shut the [ __ ] up
shut the [ __ ]
up shut the [ __ ] up shut the [ __ ] up
donny
and they'll all cross paths with a who's
who of that guys
that girls and the late great psh
in this wishful film and fantasy for
aging men who dream of bowling all day
in their pjs then getting paid a lot of
money to smoke weed and have
responsibility-free sex with a woman who
doesn't care about how gross your
apartment is
living the dream dude so watch the coen
brothers and roger deakins team up for a
visual delight
that feels like it exists outside of
time because even though it's set in the
90s
and the villains are totally 80s
fighting characters who are stuck in the
60s and 70s who are trapped in a film
noir caper straight out of the 40s and
50s
it still somehow makes perfect sense
like there's something at the center of
it all that just kind of
ties the whole thing together you know
whoa
starring the fabulous baked boy
forrest grump shut the [ __ ] up donnie
a one a to who a three
pumpkin spice hoffman they called me by
your name
urbane cowboy ares god of war
but wait there's julianne moore oh hey
it's amy mann
and flip flop a triple dip a whip whip
skateboard
high crimes and bliss demeanors
the coen brothers killed steve you semi
and miller's crossing cut him down to
just a leg in fargo
and turned him into ash and lebowski
that dude is so getting vaped in their
next movie
today is a special day yeah well you
know
that's just like your opinion man cbd
oil is just diet weed
if you can dodge a wrench you can dodge
a ball
you're gonna make me lose my mind up in
here
up in here